[Musique]
martine michel c'est pas le jour n'est
bon soir
juste avant d'entrer dans nos sujets ont
le cabinet du ministre karma en
référence à cette histoire des
adolescents qui depuis neuf mois dorment
sur le plancher du gymnase à rouyn
on nous dit qu'ils vont réintégrer leurs
charmes d'ici vendredi
ça vient de tomber alors
apparemment que québec compte absolument
pas au courant tirs qu'on a sauté comme
tout le monde quand on a vu cette
histoire sur notre site ce matin bon
autre histoire sur notre site ce qui a
fait réagir celle de thomas sur martin /
rl l'audience il ya un courriel que
thomas dénicher la débusquer entre
copains qui l'a lu et je vous montre des
petites parties du courriel où on dit
selah sue ministe qui envoie à deux
ministres
je viens d'être informé d'une situation
très percutante pour le siège celle des
arènes le résultat est qu'il n'y a
presque plus perte de personnel pour
prendre soin des 154 résidents lesieu se
prit le relais poursuites ont pour
donner les services quand on finit en
disant c'est très problématique donc
lumière qui se sont allumés la souris
n'est ski qui parle aux deux ministres
question est ce que il fallait est ce
qu'il y avait assez d'un 10 là pour
sonner la cloche général martin quelques
mots et après je vous faire entendre des
extraits
d'abord c'est pas blanc ou noir ailleurs
plusieurs zones grises lensois il ya dix
jours où rien je de dix jours entre la
publication entre courriel là qui est
envoyée au cabinet de la ministre
marguerite blais et la publication de
l'histoire des reines qui nous a tous
fait sursauter qui est un moment pivot
dans la pandémie le cancan cette
histoire les publié dans la gazette sur
le ch et celle des arènes alors quand le
premier ministre dit aujourd'hui
si on avait su c'est sûr qu'on aurait
pas laisser ça allait je pense qu'on
peut le croire au moment où le courriel
arrive avec la mention urgent on est
toujours 18 de la pandémie alors on
commence à prendre pas qu'une
connaissance de l'ampleur mais quand
même
qu'ils ne se soit pas passé de suivi
entre le moment où on est informé et la
publication de l'histoire dans la
gazette c'est un peu surréel parce que
là ça pète de partout là il ya de plus
en plus de ces achats celle d où il ya
des éclosions et ça c'est vraiment très
surprenant qu'on s'en soit on est tous
mis ça dans les mains du ciel on a
attendu la pollution tout à l'heure on
l'est on l'airé coûtera pole position je
parle à nous aimant régime ne sont pas
allés à l'extrait de la ministre il
monsieur legault qui eux se défendent et
on revient tout de suite
je n'ai pas être sur la défensive
j'ai fait tout ce que j'étais capable de
faire quand un établissement nous dit
qu'il prend en charge
ces achats celle des privés on le croit
on disait lesieu de l'ouest de l'île
brand charge la situation dans ces eps
vii des erreurs c'est ce qu'on dit dans
un courriel donc c'était rassurant
sincèrement est-ce que quelqu'un ici qui
pensent que si danielle mccann
marguerite blais ou moins on avait été
au courant de ce qui se passe est très
lent sièges celle des erreurs qu'on
aurait bien fait
bon alors voilà défense paul est ce que
est ce que ce courriel la a été on n'est
pas dans la tête des ministres qui l'ont
lu le
mais est ce qu'il aurait dû produire
d'autres effet selon vous il y aurait dû
avoir un suivi de toute évidence eu un
problème de communication
on comprend que à l'époque épaules le
seul courriel et ses dépôts le seul ch
et celle d où on y compte commencer à
observer deux des problèmes vraiment
critique et il y aura un suivi dans le
sens où l'établissement le 6e décidé de
prendre le relais donc le problème c'est
l'étape suivante est ce qu'il ya eu une
communication adéquate entre le ch et
celle de erwin le 6 et le ministère
la réponse de toute évidence c'est non
parce que sinon ça voudrait dire que le
gouvernement savait énorme bien fait
donc je pense que le problème c'est de
comprendre où est ce que la
communication a été brisée et la
responsabilité politique
au final elle échoua à la ministre donc
c'est pour la responsabilité politique
mais en géant de voir le rapport la
coroner pour comprendre qui actuellement
ne pas communiquer parce que c'est grave
que l'information ne se soit pas rendu à
temps pour qu'il y ait l'intervention
qui réside à aborder en avant bon et
comme vous dites on a très très hâte de
lire ce rapport de cette coronaire à
martyn thomas nous rappelait la c6 la
fin du printemps c'est demain matin on
verra
qu'est ce qu'ils en aient masquer
sa note ça ne provoque pas pile quand
les gens étaient interviewés sur la rue
aujourd'hui pas le genre commencé avec
vous tour de table là dessus on a perdu
michel mais vont peut-être venir
c'est pas une nouvelle mesure je pensais
ça qu'il faut retenir il ya une question
de prudence que les gens se disent bien
pourquoi pas dans le fond pas
surtout que quand on avait annoncé à
l'époque la fin du masque ce serait pour
le 15 avril c'est comme si on avait un
peu une équité notre index on l'avait
entendu dans l'air qui ont cité la 1re
div zoom standard il savait que la
deuxième on ne savait pas exactement où
on en script et c'est la moindre des
choses qu'on prolonge cette mesure parce
que si si les les scientifiques disent
que c'est la chose à faire excellemment
la meilleure façon de combattre la
sixième bague parce qu'on veut pas
ajouter de mesures coercitives du genre
fermer les établissements mais vivent
avec le virus ça veut dire mieux tracer
des pistes et mieux intervenir dans les
établissements santé et peut-être aussi
les gestes barrières comme le mas donc
si les médecins si les experts disent
que ça aide à atténuer l'ampleur de la
6e balle il me semble que les
conséquences
irritant pour la population sont
possibles michel vous revoilà vous êtes
à paris je le souligne on parlera des
des élections va faire une émission
ensemble dimanche sur le premier tour je
pense que j'ai entendu ma question mais
c'était à propos du masque vous à paris
dans un autre monde dopés à beaucoup de
masques autour de vous la
jeune avoue un peu près pas sauf
peut-être un peu de transports en commun
et quelques personnes de façon
individuelle ne s'est pas quelque chose
de général et ça fait un bout que c'est
pour général moi je me suis fié aux
conseillers officiels et je me suis
rendu compte que tout le monde me
regardait un peu comme
vous êtes au besoin de percer ici
l'entrée d'un commerce que vous devez
mettre
alors c'est vraiment complètement seul
et zyban ils ont appliqué une autre
système de mesure sanitaire championnat
mais ça ne veut pas dire que yokote
contagion ici ça veut pas dire que ils
ont pas des crêpes pour pour cette
sixième bague eux aussi oui martin je le
disais plus tôt en tout cas ce qu on a
atteint les échos bien reçu mais il ya
éric duhaime et je vous montre un tweet
c'est hier je crois qu'il ya 10 le
québécois seront les bons derniers à
devoir porter le masque obligatoirement
jusqu'au 30 avril minimum france sur le
goût d'un paul courage annoncé sa
mauvaise décision il se cache encore
derrière la santé publique alors il
monsieur duhaime qui incidemment
actuellement à la minute on se parle ou
dans quelques minutes va annoncer
officiellement qu'il sera candidat dans
chauveau lui cessé de l'eau au moulin
pour lui bien sûr c'est cocasse un peu
comment ça a été fait aujourd'hui l'on
n'est pas tombé en bas notre chaise de
monsieur le goût avait pas mal fait son
lit hier l'on se doutait bien que le
masque resterait jusqu'à la fin du mois
aujourd'hui quand on a publié le
communiqué au gouvernement on n'a pas
mis date dans le communiqué on a laissé
le docteur boileau le dira probablement
jusqu'à la fin du mois d'avril mais on
sait laisser des portes ouvertes pour
lever la mesure plutôt si c'était
possible de le faire on avait un peu
l'impression que dans son miroir le
gouvernement voyait éric duhaime
approcher et effectivement elle témoigne
de ce qui se passe à paris mais en
ontario ici il n'ya pas de masque
effectivement payé seulement
l'île-du-prince-édouard aujourd'hui
qu'annoncé quelconque qui conserverait
le mas dans les espaces publics alors un
effectivement parmi les derniers bons
ballons jean tour de table sur monsieur
duhaime dans chauveau gérard deltell a
été élu lâche et un endroit paul vous
connaissez bien québec là vous avez
couvert la politique tu en as droit où
monsieur je ne peux avoir du succès
oui tout à fait f je sais qu'en 2015 ya
une élection partielle et la libérale
des rené tremblay l'avait emporté mais
vraiment c'est l'exception qui confirme
la règle le gouvernement couillard
venait d'être élu il est encore
relativement populaire peut-être que les
gens avaient eu l'ouverture d'esprit de
fours sont frottés du côté du pouvoir
mais si vous regardez à plus long terme
la tendance s'étant watts beaucoup plus
une boîte plus conservateurs en avons la
preuve c'est quadrillé pour you l'ancien
chef du parti conservateur se présentait
dans chauveau donc je pense que l'écurie
jetée avait réussi à se faire élire leur
chef
gilles taillon gilles taillon oui martin
et comment
comment vous pouvez décrire l'état
d'esprit là des des troupes autour
d'éric duhaime là qu'on voit les
prochains on a tous prochains sondages
j'imagine oui eh ben je vous dirais que
le caucus de québec est très très
nerveux et on le sent ils sentent que
monsieur james ou fleurs s'ouvrent dans
le dos c'est sûr que monsieur duhaime
occupent un terrain inoccupé au québec
la droite et lan espace est libre et il
est très positionner sur certains enjeux
on parlait des mesures sanitaires non on
va peut-être parler du tramway un petit
peu plus tard mais sur le tramway sa
position il est clair et les fermes et
les contres alors il y occupe un espace
qui inoccupés et il est talentueux et il
ya l'expérience de la dq ix était là lui
à la dq en 2007 et il a appris et c'est
exactement ce qui reproduit sur les
mêmes terrains d'ailleurs mais parle aux
gens du tramway un michel si vous avez
même de paris suivi ça monsieur legault
qui dit finalement demain on conseille
dix minutes je vais remettre les clés
c'est à dire le décret pour autoriser le
tramway à québec mais il faudra que le
maire nous prouve que les québécois en
vain la commande ou décoder ce qui se
passe
ça peut souffler le chaud et le froid
c'était oui je vais te donner td td
grève mais sur me trouver quelque part
comment on sait pas apprécié et un
sondage son propos des lignes ouvertes
pagaille est au courant qu'il ya des
appuis populaires pour ça j'ai envie de
retourner questions monsieur legault
prouvez moi qu'ils aient un appui
général de montréal on discutera du
québec à un moment donné c'est pas on
peut pas demander aux maires de dire
trouve moins toi maintenant que tu es
l'acceptabilité sociale versées serre
ça marche pas comme ça c'est mal qu'un
responsable de centimètres et si la
maman du québec décident qui ne veut
plus parce qu'ils n'aiment pas que le
maire fait financer le très bon
sortiront du projet mais mode n'essaie
pas d'aider à buffalo un sondage ça
marche ça marche pas comme ça chacun ses
responsabilités chacun ses juridictions
et nature bas c'est très clair que
revenons d'un monsieur duhaime
députée de québec sentent qu'ils
retrouvent dans le coup et c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire est là qu est ce
que fais tu aimes 2010 il faut un
référendum si le tramway non il faut
mettre
autre chose et il change de position
mais une nuit à l'acceptabilité sociale
de part puisque les minus salaire puis
2e
ballack est
extrêmement rigides aux épaules est ce
que monsieur legault dans votre esprit
propositions quand même davantage en
faveur du maire ne voulant pas être
perçu comme quelqu'un qui est absolument
contre le transport en commun donc
concluent les mesures pour venir au giec
après que comment vous voyez ce qui
s'est passé depuis trois jours ben je
vois qu'il ya eu un tir dans des
serveurs pour le tramway le gouvernement
de soumettre ces projets de loi à la
population via des référendums il ira
pas au conditionnel à une victoire dans
un sondage comme je le dis c'est pas la
même chose pour la reine ne sais pas non
plus la même chose pour le troisième
bien j'ai peut-être manqué quelque chose
dans l'actualité myope
troisième billet si on n'a pas une
majorité de gens en faveur de on ne sait
pas trop où donc on ne sait pas qui pour
donner son opinion
de telle façon qu'ils veulent vérifier
et surtout durant cette espèce de
campagne andy mais deux sondages jour
verra c'est quoi le mécanisme je viens
de voir ça sera quoi la position de
monsieur lebon et de son gouvernement
parce que l'acceptabilité sociale
comprend que c'est important mais c'est
pas comme quand on n'est pas encore
parue dans science fiction sont
découvertes qui essayent de feu jury si
l'acceptabilité sociale existe ou donc
indépendamment de la volonté du
gouvernement le gouvernement peut
augmenter ou diminuer l'acceptabilité
sociale par son discours en ce moment
j'entends tous les arguments en défaveur
que ceux en faveur
ben voilà
y'avait pas d'acceptabilité sociale pour
le métro de montréal les commerçants et
avait peur que ça le rend l'est de la
clientèle succès amène au centre-ville
pour rappel gestion ou appartements pas
la tum cher parce que ça les
contractuels ils seraient jamais
construire le métro la
politique le très corsé qui est en train
de se jouer présentement parce que ce
que le gouvernement essaie de faire là
c'est
d'amener monsieur marchand le maire de
québec à se mouiller sur son projet
régional en disant ben oui ok je peux
faire ce que vous voulez faire à québec
mais il ya des gens dans les banlieues
qui contribuent à l'essor économique de
québec qui veulent pouvoir voyager ou
ici et on voudrait que le projet soit
régional monsieur marchand se prononcer
pour sa propre ville en même temps
monsieur marchand doit certainement
entendu aussi éric duhaime qui comptera
lors il n'y a pas tellement le choix
aussi de danser un peu avec monsieur
legault s'il veut avoir son projet alors
ça fait une joute politique assez tendue
pour l'instant et vont se rajouter
rapidement
si j'étais une mauvaise foi le jeu le
support mais je rappellerai que la
démarche du gouvernement du québec s'est
dit c'est nous qui finançons
via l'argent de l'ensemble des
contribuables privé le projet donc qui
va se prononcer sur notre amour et les
citoyens de québec des banlieues où tous
les contribuables qui le finance je dis
pas ça l'aurait l'ensemble la population
du québec au contraire je pense que
c'est aussi la capitale-nationale désire
l'acceptabilité sociale on voit que la
logique du gouvernement
plumania des endroits insoupçonnés mais
si on élargit le cercle tout ça
s'inscrit dans une volonté d'améliorer
l'offre de transport en commun pour
carrément une voiture solo par exemple
vous avez fait un texte intéressant paul
ce matin sur à ben oui mais il faut il
faut être réaliste ça je peux pas qu'il
faut continuer un peu pompeux pompeux
pas
comment vous inscrivez par rapport à
votre texte ce qui est en train
d'arriver à québec le sto bon exemple
justement dont il yad un côté plus le
statut cros de l'eau des gens qui
voudraient faire changer les choses
si c'est le rapport du giec qui a été
déposée hier hall avantage de monter des
solutions concrètes pour essayer de
ralentir le réchauffement climatique une
de ces solutions évidemment c'est le
transport en commun qui bat lien est
assez facile à faire le gouvernement
pourrait faire la promotion plus
activement du projet puis parler des
qualités et pas seulement des
désavantages de leur point de vue du
projet est aussi mettre l'accent
davantage sur les solutions au juste je
termine rapidement sur le fait que le
gouvernement a raison dire mais
l'opposition où vous parlez de style
sans jamais dire comment vous allez les
atteindre montrez nous comment vous
seriez capable de faire plus que ce que
nous en promet donc offert l'accès au
meurtre sur les mesures et non pas sur
les objectifs basés sont pas grand chose
mais le tramway mais ces mesures parce
que martin ça fera partie de la
prochaine campagne ne veut pas ce grand
thème du réchauffement climatique
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pas chaque parti a émis ses cibles
québec solidaire c'est ses 55% le
premier ministre a parlé de 60 mais ses
55% et québec solidaire et ceci ce que
monsieur legault lui a dit le thé vous
avez des cibles importantes mais vous
nous dites pas comment vous allez y
arriver et ça c'est un peu la question
c'est bon pour atteindre des cibles de
ce niveau là
c'est quand même assez élevé le
gouvernement sa cible de la caq ses 38 5
enfin si mais c'est ça alors est-ce que
la 4s que les crises vont imposer des
péages sur les ponts des autoroutes
payantes ou est ce qu'on s'en voir avec
ça on n'a pas d'idée on va en reparler
michel on veut se reparle des
présidentielles vous êtes à paris c'est
bien parce qu'un vrai campagne qui
commence macron commence à avoir chaud
la
bbc publié ce soir par paris match m au
premier tour macron 27 le pen 24 23 ces
os 4.2 d'écart ça ça s'appelle la marge
d'erreur puis monsieur bah quoi vexer
les g des grottes latour français le
comédien il y en avait avec tous les
candidats présidents ce seuil ne s'est
pas présenté ce thème à cran c'est comme
ça devant celle du diable un but je
préfère une élection je vois ça on en
reparle lanta à port salut salut au
revoir pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit